is crazy y'all this person
had a butt plug in and went to go get an
MRI did suing the butt plug people
because the butt plug had a metal core
but and a butt plug accelerated at the
speed of sound into the client's chest
cavity wow when you leave in the house
and you thinking about all the things
you need to put on like I'm like let me
go and get my MRI okay I got my hat my
kids my wallet um didn't eat anything
they just said not to eat anything so I
probably shouldn't eat anything because
I don't want them to see you walking at
you like
but I gotta have my butt plug in so you
go get your butt plug
put your Buckle again and then you go
get your MRI
maybe it's even worse you forgot the
butt plug was in like damn how
comfortable is this